- Partout au Canada, le nombre
d'hospitalisations causées par
des blessures est en baisse
sauf dans une seule catégorie :
celle des accidents de vélo.
- Ça m'étonne pas. Moi j'ai été
victime d'accidents une couple
de fois. Des gens qui parlaient
sur leur cellulaire, qui
mettaient pas leurs flashers.
- En 2020-2021, plus de
5000 cyclistes ont été
hospitalisés, une augmentation
de 25 % à l'échelle du Canada
et de 20 % au Québec.
On dénombre également plus
de 43 000 visites de cyclistes
à l'urgence, une hausse de 36 %.
- Il y a beaucoup plus de
cyclistes et peut-être aussi
les automobilistes sont pas
vraiment conscients des
cyclistes sur la route.
- On croit que c'est
la popularité croissante
du vélo qui explique
cette augmentation marquée
des accidents, mais aussi
la pandémie, qui a encouragé
les Canadiens à f
d'activités physiques.
TANYA KHAN, Institut canadien
d'information sur la santé
- Peut-être qu'ils ont passé
beaucoup de temps à l'extérieur
et ont pu essayer de nouvelles
activités, comme le vélo,
qu'ils n'auraient pas
nécessairement essayé dans
le passé. Et cela a pû entrainer
une augmentation des blessures.
- Sans grande surprise,
l'Institut nous apprend aussi
que deux fois plus d'hommes
que de femmes ont été
hospitalisés à la suite
d'un accident de vélo.
- Je pense que les filles on
est plus attentive aux règles
ou on les suit plus.
- Pour Vélo-Québec,
ces nouvelles données sont
la preuve qu'il faut accélérer
la consolidation du réseau
de pistes cyclables.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS RHEAULT,
PDG Vélo Québec
- Pour sécuriser les cyclistes,
il y a deux choses qui sont
importantes. La première
c'est la construction
d'infrastructures cyclables,
séparées de la crculation
routière, puis la deuxième
chose, c'est l'apaisement
de la vitesse des automobiles.s.
- Dans l'avenir, dit-il,
il faudra aussi surveiller
le dossier des rapides et
silencieux vélos à assistanceéle
transport peu réglementé,
même s'il cause beaucoup
de frictions sur les voies
cyclables.
- Lorsqu'on a des enfants sur
une piste cyclable et des vélos
qui roulent à 32 km/h, c'est
certainement pas compatible.- Ct
maintenant l'expérience
presque quotidiennement.
- C'est pour ça que je viens
d'acquérir un petit rétrovis
qui est absolument
indispensable, mais même à ça,
aujourd'hui il y a en a un qui
m'a doublé extrêmement vite
et j'ai et j'ai et j'ai et j'ai.
- En 2020-2021, près de
800 cyclistes canadiens ont
subi une lésion cérébrale à
la suite d'une chûte à vélo.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon